oui c'est un symbole pour
pour tous ceux le peuple de france en
disant qu' il ya encore des personnes
qui
des français qui s'élève et qui
demandait à vivre leur vie
comme ils l'ont vécu par le passé et
nous emprisonner par des lois qui sont
ils sont souvent abject
[Musique]
cette pandémie
depuis deux ans elle a créé une fracture
dans toutes les toute la société
française dans toutes les familles
dans toutes les entreprises partout dans
toutes les associations et on est arrivé
une sorte d'apartheid avec des gens qui
sont qui sont vaccinées d'autres qui
sont pas vaccinés remonte les uns contre
les autres et donc il ya maintenant
presque des des français de ceux de 2e
catégorie ou dessous zones qui ont
maintenant des des libertés des droits
qui sont restreints cours
à convoi ben c'est tout simplement une
volonté
une action vers la liberté justement
c'est une volonté
il versait sera universel une volonté
commune
de faire valoir certains droits
certaines libertés fondamentales qui
feinte pour nous sont fondamentales
j'étais des premiers combats des gilets
jaunes et donc j'étais dans les dents
les premiers sur amiens et là je sûr
j'ai repris mon sac et puis en direction
de paris pour pouvoir comment dire
défendre ses libertés qui nous sont
chères au peuple de france quoi
c'est
manifester notre mécontentement face à
toutes les mesures de l'époque sont pas
corrects face à la méprise du
gouvernement par rapport au peuple
toutes les interdictions et à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
le canton vaud ne serait-ce que le prix
du carburant c'est plus possible c'est
du possible les gens qui vont travailler
ils ont un budget carburant alors pour
les gens qui ont des enfants ils ont
déjà bu j'ai nourri son soutien budget
carburant qui est assez conséquent au
final
c'est plus possible ses vues possible
y'a pus 3 3 classes sociales on est en
train de faire deux classes sociales ses
ou tu t'en sors on dit souvent tu t'en
sors
trois mots regarde vérité la liberté
vérité les résistances c'est l'heure
c'est la liberté du peuple la vérité sur
ces d'aisance sur ces deux ans de
blocage de la france par deux élites et
ensuite al la résistance la résistance
que le peuple montre vis-à-vis de nos
dirigeants est qui et qui
faut pour faire voir qu'on est encore
toujours lors qu'on est toujours là et
on sera toujours là
c'est réservé la date n'en parlera 14h32
la stratégie c'est de prendre les routes
départementales
comme ça on n'embête personne on va au
rythme donc champêtre on a le plaisir de
découvrir le paysage pour que nos amis
nordistes et puis voilà quoi en plus il
fait beau on n'est pas pressé on est en
début ce soir 19 heures
et bal ce soir la capitale quoi 19
heures
[Musique]